[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sion par
les sports aujourd'hui c'est le dernier
numéro de cette année 2020 sur tv 78
nous nous sommes mis sur leur 31 à cette
occasion à l'occasion de cette fête de
fin d'année pour parler de l'actualité à
sportive locale yvelinoise nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous en plateau
via écran interposé pour décortiquer
cette actualité à présentation il fait
son grand retour en plateau aujourd'hui
dans cette émission c'est une légende on
ne le présente plus il fait partie de
l'histoire de ce talk il a de nombreux
fans dans le département et à travers le
monde genlis ex entraîneur de rugby de
plaisir pour avec nous mais bonjour à
tous quant aux années où il a très bien
fait longtemps que vous appelez en
plateau et ça fait plaisir de revenir en
plateau enfin les chemins ça fait
plaisir de revenir ici c'est le plaisir
est partagé en pleine forme et voilà
prêt prêt à débattre d'accord vous avez
bien réalisé comme d'habitude impeccable
là c'est un peu moi peut-être on verra
ça on passe de l'autre côté à musique
vous reconnaissez sa musique les de
nouveau présent sur ce plateau prix des
journalistes chez tv 78 est une
encyclopédie vivante sur le sport
hesdinois mais c'est également notre
italiana lover son surnom dans cette
émission la star de ce talk eux le très
élégant grégory canale est avec nous
bonjour amical bonjour à tous quand
allez-vous grégory l'écouté très bien
même si le sport continue de nous
émouvoir et les sportifs continuent de
10 pas de disparaître cette saison ont
parlé la dernière fois de kobe bryant de
maradona est de christophe dominici ya
aussi paolo rossi qui évoque beaucoup de
souvenirs de mon enfance mon grand père
reste années 2020 tout à fait je n'ai
pas pareil je les passais pas été
contemporain de ses ex points en 82 lors
de la coupe du monde 82 mais mon grand
père on a parlé énormément de paolo
rossi je me rappelle des coupures de
presse dans dans son garage donc c'est
avec émotion et aussi bas la disparition
monsieur gérard houllier une nouvelle
page en tout cas du sport qui se tourne
malheureux c'est ça une triste années
2020 l'hystérie 2020 mais bon on va
parler de sport quand même on va essayer
de redonner le sourire aux yvelines on
va essayer alors nous serons donc 3 en
plateau les autres sont avec nous via
écran interposé à cause du contexte
sanitaire je le disais précédemment
musique on le surnomme dans cette
émission le capitaine il est champion du
monde sur piste masters il est licencié
au club de vélizy 78 il adore ans par
année mais il va laisser un peu la
parole aux autres dans cette émission le
capitaine yann dujarrier est avec nous
vient du jarrier comment allez-vous
super super on voit le bout du tunnel là
ça y est les fêtes de fin d'année
arrivent on va pouvoir rapidement à
l'attaqué janvier et pouvoir
reprendre peut-être des activités en
groupe on espère en tout cas j'espère
vous allez laisser la parole aux autres
un petit peu alors pour l'avoine
normalement je prends tout puisqu'ils
ont rien bosser et moi j'ai bossé au
taquet après pour le reste lui les
sports annexes jouga leur lycée
il n'y a pas de sport annexes ans je
tiens à le préciser lui aussi est
connecté via écran interposé musique qui
nous vient tout droit de versailles
c'est un véritable gladiateur il adore
combattre dans l'arène avec ses
arguments vous l'adorez il adore les
yvelines pierre chevalier est avec nous
dans cette émission du rugby-club de
versailles ou devrais je dire le père
noël pierre chevalier j'ai envie de vous
dire oh oh les amis
fort des bonheurs et jallet s'est pas
trop une tenue gladiateurs
ces deux gladiateurs du froid un petit
peu j'ai appris il comprend que la prod
bat contre une nappe à tue-tête unis que
rouge en tout cas je vois que tout le
monde a joué le jeu et ça fait plaisir
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission hameau de voile comme vous le
savez un évinois participe au vendée
globe 2020 louis burton originaire de
rambouillet le skipper du 60 18 est
actuellement vers l'australie
après plus d'un mois de course à bord de
son bureau vallée de il est pour
l'instant dans le top 10 du classement
général mais attention il perd du
terrain il nous explique tout cela dans
cette vidéo
alors
pour ceux qui se demandent pourquoi
j'étais dans cette zone ya pas de vent
c'est pas dans mes habitudes
et 20 en fait c'est parce que j'avais
besoin de répondre à une problématique
qu'on m'a posée comment tu sais si tu
déchires dévoile
voilà
donc voilà à quoi ressemble un atelier
voilerie
dans médium
le fait du match difficile
comme tout en trouvant preneur que dans
le bateau civil c'est le moyen c'était
de
venir dans cette veine 100 ans
j'ai plein d'oiseaux des albatros écart
et moi ça fait
parce que forcément ça me fait perdre du
terrain mais j'ai déjà pu réparer
complètement m'a presque complètement ma
grand-voile
jean une petite réaction
ces actions il a pris le
chemin miscou on va dire parce qu'il y
ait moins de moines de moins de 20 mai
pour réparer il avait besoin de réparer
bon mais voilà ce sont les aléas des
aléas de la course et elle est loin
d'être terminée juste j'en profite un
petit message petit mathis qui a 5 ans
et qui suit le vendée globe imaginez
vous quand même comme quoi ceux qui
gèrent des générations comme quoi voilà
comme quoi toutes les générations seront
ceux touchés par cet événement national
n'a qu'un petit mathis qui vient des
îles il ou pas du tout non vie n'est pas
loin des ballons il est juste à côté
d'accord ok dans l'essonne non pas du
tout avec enfin que val de marne val de
marne alors il est 8ème pour l'instant
ducation général grégory est ce que
c'est quand même une belle performance
malgré tout on le voit qu'il a quelques
petits soucis quand même quelques petits
soucis on rappelle que son objectif il
avait dit il avait terminé septième lors
de sa dernière participation s'est
terminée une place au dessus donc au
moins d'être dans le top 6 ils ont
franchir les skippers les 50% de course
ils sont désormais on va dire dans la
deuxième partie de ce vendée globe dont
qui reste aussi beaucoup beaucoup à
parcourir huitième place pour lui pour
le moment une petite dégringolade mais
il reste encore encore forte à faire
donc moi je me fais pas plus de soucis
que ça la presse est très serrée 1
pierre chevallier en le voit sur les
images
les autres bateaux sont quand même à
proximité ils les voient dans un
mouchoir de poche
pierre chevalier
nous avons perdu pierre chevallier yann
alors du coup je oui oui bien sûr vous
donnait la parole alors vu que vous êtes
notre spécialiste voile mais mais bon
les aléas du direct fait parfois des
choses juppé salit de rien du tout mais
je me passionne pour cette course voilà
et en effet c'est vrai que là il ya une
forte densité dans les
5e à la 10e place on a on a attendu que
l'unité tout à l'heure voilà on a cinq
concurrents en cinq en 50 milles
nautiques donc c'est vraiment très très
faible les positions changent très très
régulièrement et quasiment tous les
jours d'ailleurs à ce niveau là et c'est
vrai que l'on a vu des vidéos où tous
les hutus se sont filmés des uns et des
autres et c'était assez assez marrant de
de pouvoir voir voilà après après 38
jours de course de voir que les bateaux
pouvaient encore être d un côté les
autres et c'est une particularité cette
année puisque j'ai fait un petit
comparatif avec
avec l'édition 2010 2016 2017 ou et bien
à ce moment-là louis burton était était
8e au 6e au classement général sauf que
à ce moment là ils avaient ils avaient
ils avaient déjà de 2,2 plus de 1000
mine de type de retard sur sur la tête
de course et c'est vrai que c'était
vraiment vraiment impressionnant c'est
vraiment impressionnant
las de voir cette année cette densité de
aux deux coureurs et des voir tous aussi
proches les uns des autres alors que
annonce était pas du tout caler les
années les années précédentes on a
vraiment une course qui est passionnante
justement du fait de cette densité d
cette densité de deux bateaux aussi
proches les uns des autres après une
après autant de jours de course voilà
c'est cette fois une part gagné ou pas
du tout il ya dujarrier
est aujourd'hui si je regarde le
classement il ay la simple haïlé à 511
milles nautiques de retard
en effet en fait il appel il a perdu 511
milles nautiques en moins d'une semaine
c'est à dire que quand on s'est quittés
il ya quinze jours il venait de prendre
la deuxième place
et dans les jours qui ont suivi il est
remonté jusqu'à moins de 100 milles
nautiques donc donc voilà là aujourd'hui
en fait en un peu plus d'une semaine et
sur les derniers jours d'ailleurs pas ce
que c'est ces problèmes techniques sont
apparus en milieu de semaine dernière et
donc un il est là il a commencé à les
résoudre seulement enfin il a fini de
les résoudre seulement la laisser ces
derniers jours et donc voilà il a accusé
un retard de plus de 500 de près de 400
milles nautiques simplement sur les îles
perdait 100 milles nautiques par jour de
sueur sur la tête donc vu la distance
qu'il reste il reste à parcourir onze
mois ce que j'ai vu sur en suivant très
très près son bateau fait partie des
bateaux les plus rapides quand il est à
100% maintenant la question c'est est ce
qu'il va réussir à récupérer un bateau à
100% d'ici la fin de la course c'est
tout s'il arrive à à cela ben oui
peut-être que je suis sûr c'est que s'il
arrive à récupérer un bateau à 100% il
va regagner des places ça c'est clair
elle est remontée jusqu'à la tête on
verra bien parce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier une chose c'est yannick baisse
de rêve est à peine aujourd'hui à
a eu la compensation de temps qui lui
est imparti pour le sauvetage de deux
pme du marin de prb et donc il va
exposer le 10h15 de 10h15 de
compensation le temps jean le cam lui ce
sera 16h15 et boris herrmann qui avait
été aussi déplacé aura six heures donc
je sais que c'est la fin d'un cours sans
pardon ça peut jouer sur la fin de
course évidemment tout à fait ça parce
que faut pas faux on pense que c'est pas
grand chose mais avec les moyennes
qu'ils ont qui sont à peu près autour de
30 km/heure ben quand on a 10 heures à
10 heures à récupérer c'est quand même
plus de 300 kilomètres donc donc voilà
c'est vrai qu'il ya une ça va être je
pense moi un vrai suspense jusqu'à
l'arrivée et comme on l'avait eu l'année
dernière il ya quatre ans mais là il ya
quatre ans à se jouer cinq mois entre
les deux premiers du classement là il ya
vraiment un noyau de voile et je dirais
encore une flotte
pierre chevallier on vous a pas entendu
du coup on vous a perdu on vous retrouve
je m'étais barret c'était pour le début
de la présentation de yens
je fais une petite pause comme ça à la
moitié s'étaient très bien petit café je
voulais juste a ajouté que le jus
comment les classements changé avec
notamment les gratifications pour ces
sauvetages en haute mer le tout peut
changer dans la deuxième partie de la
course et notamment la quand on regarde
ce classement là et ce au classement de
13 qui a dit il ya quelques jours on a
on a on avait quasiment une modification
presque au total sur les 8 premiers donc
donc temps qui tient et tant qu'il fait
ces ateliers de couture on rappelle à ce
moment là que que ce sont vraiment des
aventuriers au long cours et qui sont
capables de tout faire en plus d'être
cuisiné en plus d'être marin et en plus
d'être d'être spécialiste de cours
d'orientation c'est ma
licence
je comprends bien
il y avoir une part des sciences
forcément gens dans
le parcours de weezer tonnes on voit que
là il a pas forcément de chance avec sa
voile il en faut 1 il est plein de
favoris qui ont par exemple la bande et
1 samantha davies qui était pas là
favori mais qu'ils auraient abandonné
récemment alex thomson six abandons et
rigoriste s'il a bien donne donc
forcément force et une grande terrasse
vous pouvez gagner le vendée globe sur
tout à fait tout à fait il ya une part
de chance puisque quand ils jouent
contre la nature et la nature mais on ne
peut pas on peut pas on peut pas tout
prévoir la naturelle et à l'arrivée
c'est elle qui gagne donc forcément il y
aura il ya une énorme part de chasse il
ya du technique mais ils sont tous
technique qui saute tous ce sont tous
des professionnels de la mer mais
forcément il y à il ya une part de
chance qui rentre dans le jeu il ya le
bateau forcément qui joue également des
solutions d accord mais en captant parle
de louis burton qui a un bateau qui est
capable de gagner le vendée globe
forcément il fait partie des
skippers qui sont capables d'aller au
bout et de finir de gagner cette
compétition mais il ya quand même
toujours une part de chasse qu'est ce
qu'on peut lui souhaiter grégory
peut-être pour pour ces fêtes de fin
d'année berthen eux deux
de rattraper on va dire son teint c'est
vrai ça a été dit tout va très vite de
la 4e à la 8e place tout se joue dans un
mouchoir de poche il ya le trio de tête
qu'un un peu plus devant sucre regarder
au dernier pointage sur la cartographie
tente un truc louis burton il a piqué
vers le sud par rapport aux autres
skippers je sois siliana a des infos là
dessus mais peut-être que c'est une
stratégie qui s'avérera payante elle ne
s'est pas attention il ya non ils
piquent pas trop au sud
tous sont très proches de la ligne de
zones d'exclusion
c'est vrai que au classement de demain
en fin de matinée il avait il avait
piqué au dessus la haie d'instruction il
faut pas lire je le rappelle il faut pas
aller trop sud justement vers la zone
arctique à baa1 la notation d'une zone
d'exclusion des glaces sur les teignes
en ligne à laquelle ils n'ont pas le
droit de franchir et on voit tout cela
maintenant
louis burton avait fait fait le cap vers
le sud très très quand on était passé
pas très loin de l'amérique du sud il
avait vraiment bien et est descendu en
plus longtemps que les autres là tout le
monde s'est rapproché d'aline des gas &
m two bonnet et à la corde
l'agent fin de toute façon on voit ce
que je n'ai ce que je me suis noter ses
avants il faut encore voir je pense faut
laisser encore quelques jours un peu de
temps pour voir les places au classement
général
voilà tout peut encore évoluer et et de
toute façon
ça va dépendre des classes de chacun ça
va dépendre de plein plein de choses à
chaque fois qu'ils ont des ânes harry
parce que les meilleurs sons sont très
cassantes à chaque fois qu'ils nous a
mariés sont obligés d'aller se mettre
dans des secteurs comme lui mortagne a
fait beaucoup buccal pour pouvoir
réparer et après ils retournent ils
retournent ce maître se mettre au
charbon donc voila tout peut encore
évoluer ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il est
dans le bon wagon pour le premier on lui
souhaite en tout cas de passer de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année à guy burton à aux
alentours de de l'australie en israël
sera vers l'australie pendant le 24 ans
normalement peut être un petit peu plus
loin on lui souhaite en tout cas le
meilleur alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du à
paris saint germain nous ferons un
premier bilan de la saison du psg coup
de projecteur également sur les as
portif yvelinois qui ont marqué cette
année à 2020 mais avant de développer
ces thèmes on va parler de la coupe de
france de football
[Musique]
la décision n'est pas encore prise mais
elle pourrait faire du bruit chez le
premier ministre jan à castex a avoué à
demi-mot qu'il serait très difficile de
terminer la coupe de france de football
cette année une compétition qui s'est
stoppée au stade du 6e tour de son côté
noël le graet le président de la
fédération française de football assure
que les instances vont tout faire pour
terminer la compétition dans les
yvelines un ce club est concerné deux
clubs de conflent qui doit affronter le
club de vitry à domicile les deux
équipes évoluent en r 1 l'entraîneur de
l'équipe carles priso a réagi
ce sera un goût d'inachevé des efforts
quelque part les points avec une bonne
préparation avec des résultats en
championnat qui était positif et puis
bah quand on continue la banque urs
écrire de façon positive mais aussi en
coupe donc voilà il ya de tout il ya de
toute l'amertume de la déception la
frustration
il réagissait bien sûr à l'annulation
pou la possible annulation de cette
coupe de france 2020-2021 de la question
sur cette thématique la coupe de france
de football doit-elle aller à son terme
oui ou non vous ôter un grand oui grand
oui à priori oui pour pierre chevallier
partagé pour jean est pour vous y allez
d'accord partager également ben pourquoi
tout simplement gens vous êtes partagés
enfin un petit duel peut-être avec avec
un gorille oui pour votre retour
anti-indiennes partager partager
pourquoi parce que parce que
sportivement bien sûr que ça doit aller
au bout bien sûr que nous avons eu lieu
mais comme toutes les disciplines qui
sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt et dont les
championnats il n'existe pas à part le
professionnalisme mais on parle là du
sport amateur et là forcément une
commune des clubs amateurs la coupe de
france mais rentrer dans ce cadre là
donc sportivement bien sûr que ça doit
aller au bout bien sûr quand on veut que
ça se fait puisqu'on est là pour le
sport mais après il ya quand même cette
pandémie qui est là qui qui en annonce
une troisième vague début d'année 2021
donc forcément alors on a relâché on
n'est pas là pour parler politique on va
relâcher pour les fêtes et on annonce
une troisième vague 2021 donc forcément
aujourd'hui personne ne peut dire quel
sport quelle discipline quel championnat
va pouvoir se dérouler normalement en
2021 par rapport à cette crise de l'aco
vide que l'on traverse depuis maintenant
presque un an quoi donc c'est pour ça
que je suis mitigé sportivement et j'ai
envie qu'elle ait lieu parce que j'ai
envie tout laisse toutes les disciplines
vive et que tous les championnats soit
fait mais après il ya cette pandémie qui
nous voilà qu'on a au dessus de la tête
c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient mitigées
grégory c'est un grand oui bon vous
savez je suis un amoureux de cette
compétition c'est aussi pour voir josas
en tout cas n'était pas qualifié
on est éliminé dès le tour de cadrage
ans et même avant le premier tour non
mais simplement pour dire on lems est
compétitive compétition c'est la seule
qui permet à des petits clubs amateurs
d'aller se frotter à plus grand que voir
des clubs professionnels s'ils vont loin
dans la compétition c'est aussi pour
vaincre apple sorte que vous me prêtez
de porter malheur au club yvelinois
j'avais fait une chronique où je parlais
voilà de voir un petit poucet évinois
aller loin dans cette compétition il y
avait sept clubs il n'en reste plus
qu'un aujourd'hui toujours là toujours
en effet force est de constater qu on
flambe affronter vitry c'est un club qui
au même niveau au niveau régional niveau
hérin donc ils peuvent aller chercher ce
7e tour après oui je j'entends les
arguments sur la crise sanitaire les
dates vont être très rare à trouver je
crois qu'il ya neuf dates de calendrier
allé chercher ça pose surtout problème
pour les clubs professionnels qui sur la
fin de saison vont encore enchaîner les
matches notamment en ligue 1 donc il ya
effectivement des contraintes au niveau
du calendrier mais pour la beauté du
sport pour la beauté de ce duel amateurs
professionnels il faut que ça aille au
bout qui a raison qui a tort pierre
chevallier alors vous étiez plus du côté
de grégory ainsi si je me trompe pas ou
plutôt du côté du côté de grégory
on s'écrit les calendriers vont être le
vrai problème de toutes les disciplines
que quel que soit chez les amateurs et
chez les professionnels aussi d'ailleurs
mais ce qui ce qui me donne ce qui me
donne une - une envie de dire oui c'est
le coup de que coûte et le en même temps
politique c'est à dire oui il ya
peut-être un manque d'équité sportive
mais en même temps il faudrait coûte que
coûte jouer cette coupe de france parce
que ça sera bon pour le moral quel qu'il
soit la fff est en train d'imaginer un
système qui serait peut-être un système
ados tableau pour faire rentrer les
clubs professionnels et les clubs
amateurs directement un niveau de
huitièmes de finale en gros parce que là
actuellement il ya ce que 7e 8e tour de
coupe de france à jouer avec les clubs
de ligue 2 qui entreraient au 8e tour on
sait qu'on pourra pas le tenir cet
agenda a donc imaginé une formule un
petit peu un petit peu l'hybride avec
deux tableaux les pros les amateurs mais
qui dormait quand même la chance au club
amateur si ça permet de voir un peu de
football en 2021 malgré une éventuelle
troisième bague ou plus ça serait de
toute façon bon pour le moral bon pour
les sportifs qui ne se serait pas
préparé pour rien lien dujarrier
jeu enfin voilà le gros problème qu'il
ya c'est que les clubs professionnels
continuent enfin eux sont en plein
dedans en plein championnat voilà que ce
soit des championnats nationaux les
championnats européens pour les pour les
très grosses écuries quoi qu'on a plus
beaucoup de clubs français en coupes
européennes mais voilà que les notes
peuvent s'entraîner et avoir des
compétitions régulièrement et nous
pauvres nos programmateurs ils ont à
peine le droit de s'entraîner entre eux
est alors pouvoir faire des matches
c'est impossible et on va leur dire ben
légal allez-y maintenant fois l'étape il
est gros fort et les choix des au
charbon
non je trouve que ça va pas être ça va
pas être équitable est donc là pour
alléger calendrier pour que tout le
monde puisse déjà simplement faire des
matchs que les amateurs jouent entre eux
face nord faster championnat de rdr de 2
d de cfa et c'est que tout le monde
puisse tu joues et tu jouais déjà et
finir ces championnats pour avoir des
montées des descentes en fin de saison
et puis la coupe de france c'est bien
cette année on aura pas de vainqueur de
la coupe de france ça serait inédit il
ya du jarrier ans en quatre ans
d'existence la coupe de france ne s'est
jamais n'a jamais été annulée
et jamais lavés n'avait jamais fait non
plus voilà et or longue avance conclu
bon ben voilà il ya une des premières
avec cette crise sanitaire c'est fait
les premières et les jeux olympiques
auront lieu la première fois lors d'une
année impaire voilà eh bien eh ben ça
arrivera aussi il faudra s'en souvenir
parce que ce seront des questions que
l'on pourra poser dans les quiz de
manière générale les questions mais qui
a gagné les jeux au lesquels 100 m des
jeux olympiques en 2020 personnes voilà
donc
ce sera je serai ce sera des jeux et
puis et puis c'est tout
il ya plein de première il y aura plein
de choses à découvrir à retenir les
comptes plus celle là
je
dis je dis allez on ne les compte plus
et grande première et c'est cette
situation inédite que ce soit dans le
sport ou dans l'actualité générale je
crois qu on est on est encore abonné
pour quelques mois de situation inédite
et grande première major
plus important quand même la coupe de
france peut-être pour les amateurs
plutôt que les professionnels on va
écouter justement karl priso
l'entraîneur de conflent le fait de
côtoyer le haut niveau ne serait ce le
temps d'un instant
oui effectivement si les les objets
qu'ils sont différents mais mac qui
veulent la gagner nous on veut aller
plus loin possible en profitant de l'
aventure des gorilles vovo confirmé
c'est ça le plus important pour les
petits clubs louis massabeau tout à fait
c'est d'aller d'aller se frotter encore
aux plus grands et serait une énorme
déception pour pour ces amateurs ils
sont 6e tour 6e tour de la coupe de
france ils sont à un tour du septième à
deux tours il me semble de l'entraidé
des clubs de ligue 1 donc on n'est pas
loin du duo niveau j'ajoute on disait
tout à l'heure la même pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale la seconde
guerre mondiale on a réussi à jouer la
coupe de france alors oui ça a été un
autre format là la france était divisé
en trois zones pour cette coupe de
france je crois qu'elle était renommé la
coupe charles simon il me semble s'être
occupé la zone non occupée c'est ça
voilà donc on a réussi quand même à la
joue et il ya un exemple dans l'histoire
il ya pas eu de vainqueur ses 92 après
le drame de furiani qui s'était déroulée
pendant les demi finales d'une coupe de
france justement trop de bastia est là
pour le coup ce n'était pas tout la
compétition
jusqu'au dernier carré effectivement et
ça serait peut-être plus simple
peut-être pour les amateurs de jouer en
parle de playoffs 2 play donne un petit
peu ce qui devrait peut-être se faire en
rugby agence à peu près ça oui mais
encore une fois encore une fois ce sont
des prévisions c'est ça le truc c'est
que personne aujourd'hui ne sait ce qui
va se passer ce début d'année dominateur
donc tout le monde il fait des
prévisions calendrier unique et nice qui
sont pas faits tout à fait tout comme on
l'a fait dans le rugby puisque nous
c'est le rugby voilà dans le rugby ils
ont faim qu'ils ont prévu un calendrier
mais c'est prévisionnel tous à ceux du
prévisionnel donc nous en tant que
sportive on espère que tout va être fait
qu'on arrive à aare ouvrir toutes les
portes et qu'on fasse tous les
championnats mais il y aura toujours
ceux mais on ne sait pas malheureusement
si ça pourra se faire alors pour être
tout à fait complet sur cette coupe de
france côté femmes deux clubs sont
également encore en course hr clubs de
d1 doit affronter poissy en coupe de
france un derby qu'on espère voir
également un
jours alors on va passer maintenant à
une nouvelle thématique mais on continue
à parler un football et plus précisément
du paris saint germain dont le centre
d'entraînement et dans les yvelines à
saint germain en laye et qui déménagera
bientôt à poissy nous avons fait un
premier bilan de la saison du psg le
club de la capitale est actuellement
qualifié pour les huitièmes de finale de
la ligue des champions en terminant
premier de son groupe devant les
allemands de leipzig en championnat
c'est un peu plus compliqué le paris
saint germain 3 elle malgré son budget
quasi sans limites le club qui compte
neymar et amap et en serrant affiche
déjà quatre défaites au compteur la
question sur ce thème le bilan du psg
est il positif jusqu'à présent oui ou
non
non non pour genlis oui pour vous et
yann partagé pour vous grégory ont fait
un petit duel peut-être entre pierre et
yan yan
vous êtes d'accord avec pierre pierre
vous êtes d'accord à cannes du coup non
pas du tout ce matin j'ai dit d'accord
allez oui j'ai dit j'ai dit oui pour
simplement l'objectif de paris est
simple c'est de gagner la ligue des
champions ils ont échoué dernièrement en
temps en finale face à face au bayern
et il faut pas oublier en plus une
informatique qui a fini très près par
est donc juste derrière il a fallu
réentraîner avec avec le championnat de
france je vais pas dire que ça explique
que les quatre défaites les quatre
défaites en championnat aujourd'hui ils
ont
ils ont deux points de retard je crois
sur sur les leaders rien de rien très
très grave et encore tu appelles qu'un
point d'ailleurs certain seuil mais il y
a des matches en retard si je réglais ça
ils ont un point de retard sur sur le
leader il aurait deux points de retard
si marseille gagne ses deux ces deux
matches en retard donc il n'y a rien de
rien d'alarmant il ya rien de
catastrophique maintenant je vais
vraiment 7,4 soit pas pour pour l'om
mais bon comment ça c'est quatre points
je crois pour repos l'om
est un point derrière ses parents
auraient pu de paris a perdu contre lyon
ce week-end tout à fait tout à fait
c'est déjà le classement je l'aï vu
c'était avant le match de ce week-end
mais voilà quatre points c'est c'est pas
du tout alarmant faut savoir que alors
oui si on prend six ont 30 classement de
l'année dernière à la même période il
avait huit points d'avancé sur le second
donc ça veut dire que quand la machine
se mettra en route ils sont largement
capables de refaire le retard est
d'écraser tout le monde l'objectif pour
eux c'est d'être devin de gagner la
ligue des champions et moi dans les
statistiques que j'avais vu faut pas
oublier une chose quand vous finissez
premier de votre poule vous avez de
mémoire près de 80% de chances de passer
le premier tour de passer les vitesses
se jouer au match retour je précise vous
recevez vous recevez votre adversaire au
match retour vous recevez votre
adversaire au match retour et 2 que
j'avais deux je me souviens j'avais
regardé j'avais fait des stats à une
époque sur trois quatre saisons et donc
quand vous étiez premier de notre poule
vous aviez 80% de chances de passer de
passer en qu'après le psg
commencé lors de la revente ada de 2017
oui mais sauf que eux ils joueront parc
est de toute façon cette année c'est
pareil c'est l'année des grands première
on l'a dit de toute façon dont chaque
année que vous jouiez à l'extérieur il
ya domicile comme c'est à huis clos ça
ne change rien c'est la même chose pour
tout le monde n'y a pas de 13e n'est pas
le douzième homme y'a pas le 12e avec le
public donc même si on annonce peut-être
un retour dans les stades en janvier
avec des avec des curseurs qui traitait
à 50% de remplacement de remplissage ou
ou inférieure enfin voilà de toute façon
pour moi ça ne sert de ça ne changera
rien et en plus voilà ils ont l'avantagé
de pouvoir recevoir le barça et la
remonte à noël ne sera que je sois
franchement je les jeux les envoyer un
message direct à un pote quand quant au
tirage a eu lieu c'est l'année de la
relance voilà c'est c'est pas vraiment
le bihan moyens surtout que le barça est
très très loin d'être d'être en grande
en grande forme donc pour l'instant moi
je pense qu'ils sont dans le haut valais
c'est peut-être pierre chevalier on en
parlera juste après du barça pierre
chevallier
pour que celles en retrait je fais juste
une petite parenthèse en disant que le
sept états du psg actuel est bon pour le
suspense de la ligue 1 ceci étant dit
d'un point de vue maintenant purement on
va dire purement professionnel du
football jeudi je dis non le bilan n'est
pas positif pour l'instant jusqu'à
maintenant sur cette saison
quelles que soient ses de la saison et
le contexte qui est le même pour tout le
monde c'est compte tenu du potentiel et
des ambitions du psg je pense
qu'actuellement le problème que le
problème de tours elle s'oppose de se
pose de plus en plus il doit y avoir des
des querelles de coulisses entre
leonardo et et tourelles
sur l'obtention de résultats probants
est notamment particulièrement les des
champions
a priori tour elle a du mal désormais à
gérer son vestiaire gérer ses stars
quand on vois l'addition de l'addition
de champion qu'il ya sur le terrain on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de dire qu'il ya
peut-être un problème de remplacement de
ces derniers partis en défense notamment
en défense et au milieu je pense à
thiago silva
à force de replacer les uns et les
autres derrière devant
toi le pen a trouvé une ossature fixe au
milieu et en défense et que la désormais
un bilan comme celui en étant à tailler
finalement par par l'île barbe young par
marseille
c'est bon pour le suspense mais le bilan
ne peut pas être positif on a certes une
finale de ligue des champions dans des
conditions particulières la saison
dernière là il passe ric rac en poule
avec surtout aussi ne le bilan n'est pas
positif en terme de spectacle et en
termes de technique ce que propose j'ai
actuellement est assez triste par
rapport à haut potentiel et par rapport
à ce qu'ils ne sont montrées jusqu'à
maintenant le barça se pointe en 8e de
finale alors moi je compléterai ce que
disait il ya disons que c'est peut-être
la revente shader plutôt que l'art au
montana et là le contexte est bon pour
ça
c'est au contraire une très belle
occasion qu'ils ont de rendre le bilan
positif mais actuellement vu le
potentiel vu le but est qu'il faut en
parler vu les stars qui a sur le terrain
c'est par contre maintenant ça montre
aussi sportivement que mon addition de
ces armes ou du moins ça met du temps à
aller chercher des gens qui vous a
convaincu pierre jan alors j'étais de la
vie de pierre donc forcément c'est ma
vie de pierre ben je serai ce lapidaire
c'est pas une langue pour moi pour moi
c'est un bilan négatif s'était mis là
négatif parce que j'ai attendu vous êtes
à lui dire le psg bila le avec des des
moyens des moyens illimités jette à lui
il ya le guide est une machine cas la
machine va se mettre en marche sauf que
alors leur objectif c'est la coupe
d'europe sauf que ça fait des années de
plusieurs années et que c'est leur
objectif la coupe d'europe d'accord ils
ont fait une finale l'année dernière
sauf que il faut quand même regarder un
petit peu la chance qu'ils ont vu sur
les tirages ou les gros entre guillemets
les gros européens se soient affrontés
entre eux et ils prenaient pas les
grosses puissances du football européen
sur les phases finales 8e l'écart même
les demies je pense quand même que ils
ont eu une part et de la part de chance
dans la voix le tout à l'heure je pense
quand même que l'année dernière ils ont
une part de chasse sur les tirages au
sort sur les phases finales ça n'enlève
pas leurs qualités et leurs performances
sportives et d'être arrivés jusqu'en
finale après le surf et le tirage mais
voilà c'est une part de chance jeudi
page est bien ce que je dis je souligne
ça ne lève pas leur leurs performances
sportives sauf qu'aujourd'hui le sg on
parle beaucoup c'est quand même la
machine de guerre yann l'a dit c'est une
machine avec budget illimité et je pense
qu'on attache énormément +2 que
simplement dire mais on n'a pas de bons
résultats en championnat cette année
parce qu'on vise la coupe d'europe mais
les autres années aussi viser la coupe
d'europe sauf qu'il survolait le
championnat il survolait vous l'avez dit
on l'a dit sur le plateau tout à l'heure
à à la même époque il avait vu points de
base alors on parle de match en retard
mashaie mais il survolait le championnat
là ils ont mis ils ont eu des défaites
cette saison en championnat qui ne
ressemble pas à la qualité de sportif de
l'équipe qui a sur le sur le championnat
depuis plusieurs années donc pour moi
c'est un bilan négatif est ce que le psg
est habitué à des débuts de saison
poussif grégory si on prend ce qui est
comparable si on parle de ce qui est
comparable c'est-à-dire depuis l'arrivée
des qataris à la tête du psg en 2011 qui
a fait passer le club de la capitale
dans une autre dimension et bien la
réponse michael et non avec déjà quatre
défaites en championnat face à lens
marseille monaco et lyon 2 en champion's
league face à manchester united et life
chiche le paris saint germain compte en
décembre autant de défaites toutes
compétitions confondues que sur
l'ensemble de la saison précédente alors
si on met le curseur sur la ligue 1
uniquement quatre défaites en 14
journées autant que montpellier qui est
cinquième à rennes qui est 8ème lens qui
est 9e cela n'était pas arrivé michael
depuis la saison 2009 2010
q et s'ils n'étaient pas encore
propriétaire qatari saint germain
antoine kombouaré était sur le banc du
paris saint germain c'est une saison qui
a été terminé à la 13e place on aime on
imagine mal un tel scénario cette saison
quand même une 13e place pour les
parisiens
cela veut dire aussi que sur glace ça
paraît très sûr quand ça paraît très
surprenant mais cela veut dire
c'est ça et ça veut dire aussi que même
sur les saisons où le paris
saint-germain dernièrement n'a pas été
champion c'est à dire la saison 2011
2012 quand c'est montpellier qui a eu
son premier sacre est aussi la saison
2016 2017 avec le titre de monaco est
bien le départ en championnat du paris
saint germain était aussi été meilleurs
donc même sur des saisons ils n'ont pas
été champions ils n'ont pas fait pire
que cette saison j'ajoute qu'au parc des
princes paris n'est plus l'équipe
imprenable sur ces dernières des
dernières années celle que l'on a connue
sur les dernières années notamment une
statistique à vous citer 8 points perdus
en 7 rencontres à domicile cette saison
alors il y aurait ce match contre
barcelone on a en parlé précédemment
avec avec vous et yann qui est favori
finalement donc ce sera le 16 février à
barcelone le retour le 10 mars au parc
des princes
qui est favori peut-être pierre
chevalier moi je moi je là pour le coup
je dis paris par ça et le barça est
tellement mieux en championnat de ligue
1 actuellement 8e j'avais les jambes
j'ai envie d'y croire et il ils ont ils
ont les même genre de problèmes de
vestiaires avec plutôt là quelques stars
un petit peu sur le sur la plus tôt fin
de carrière un messi messi qui est plus
aussi flamboyant c'est peut-être le
moment de la plante et cette revanche
adam jan vous êtes d'accord voilà qu'on
est d'accord tout à fait complètement
d'accord
moi je pour pourparlers pour faire le
petit curseur entre ligue des champions
et championnat je pense que le fait
d'être en retard va leur permettre de
rester sous pression jusqu'à la fin
alors que les autres années il avait
tendance à comme il avait gagné le
championnat le 15 novembre on va dire au
15 octobre c'était difficile pour eux de
rester sous pression à cette année le
fait d'être d'abord ce retard va faire
qui vont ils vont devoir rester sous
pression est donc prêt physiquement
jusqu'au bout ça peut être vraiment à un
gros une grosse chance et pour noir en
effet les difficultés du barça font que
cette année ça ne donnerait pas ça
devrait pas être une actu de une
formalité de gagner ce match mi février
et mi mars ça me paraît quand même
énorme par contre 14 sous les 24 février
encore quels seraient ces oubliés et 10
mars au parc des princes après la
saint-valentin où les récents rentable
que ça faisait l'eau ça fait l'autre
qu'il joue il au jour de la saint
valentin
et mes 10 mars voilà ça fait plus de
trois semaines encore c'est très très
long je trouve c'est dommage qu'ils
puissent pas enchaîner un petit peu
parce que en trois semaines il peut se
passer beaucoup de choses la droite et
les arcades dujarrier oui oui non mais
on est bien d'accord par contre c'est
pareil petites petites choses aussi
positif c'est que ben et marne et marc
vient de faire sa blessure et qui est il
va pouvoir se réparer pendant les fêtes
de fin d'année avec la coupure hivernale
c'est du bonheur apparemment c'est moi
au moins dangereux que ce qu'il
prévoyait auparavant une semaine ou deux
d'absence
grégory le personnel vous avez pu les
voir jouer qu'est ce que ça vaut est ce
que paris peut gagner je pense que c'est
l'année où jamais pour paris alors on
dit souvent ça du paris saint germain
mais le contexte est plutôt favorable
pour le paris saint-germain on rappelle
qu'au barça il ya eu de nombreuses
tensions cet été sur le potentiel départ
de messi finalement messi est resté des
tensions avec son président bart tomé où
qui est finalement parti c'est
bartolomeu et qui a cédé dans ce duel
face à messi une 8e place en liga ils
sont à neuf points de la tête qui est
aujourd'hui occupé par la real sociedad
et vous l'avez dit en ligue des
champions je les ai suivis parce que
étant supporters de la juventus et j'ai
regardé les matches avec attention sur
le dernier surtout le dernier où la
jeune suisse s'impose s'imposent 3 buts
à 0 moi j'ai vu dans ce barça peut-être
paraître
stéréotypé mais un messi seul dans un
marasme barcelonais pour le moment donc
je pense que c'est le moment ou jamais
après ce qu'il faut pas oublier le match
et ont fait briller peut-être que les
scénarios ont totalement évolué il faut
aussi préciser qu au paris saint germain
ça a été dit le contexte n'est pas non
plus favorable on va dire à 100% avec
des tensions entre le directeur sportif
leonardo et son entraîneur thomas storey
qui est très critiquée et en championnat
ça a été dit aller chercher cette ligue
des champions je pas forcément d'accord
avec cet objectif faut pas oublier que
le psg cette année ils peuvent aller ils
peuvent aller chercher un 10e titre en
ligne accueille saint-etienne qui a fait
mieux en ligue 1 où ils sont
actuellement à neuf titres avec
l'olympique de marseille donc il aussi
cet objectif de prendre on va dire la
première place sony au niveau du nombre
de titres dans l'histoire pour le psg
donc la ligue des champions reste certes
l'objectif principal des qatari mais
faut pas oublier le championnat alors on
va passer maintenant maintenant à notre
page débats
[Musique]
on continue notre page enfin on passe à
notre base débat c'est le moment de
votre rubrique grégory nous l'avons
baptisé à l'envolée de grégory de quoi
allez vous nous parlez de l'année 2020
au niveau du sport bien sûr comme c'est
la dernière émission avant les fêtes
alors plus particulièrement à cette
année cette émission pour les athlètes
yvin on va parler de nos athlètes dans
ces 12 derniers mois qui ont été marqués
certes par la crise sanitaire l'arrêt
des compétitions pour les amateurs mais
aussi pour les professionnels certains
de nos yvelinois ont réussi tout de même
à se distinguer qui est donc le sportif
de l'année c'est la question que je me
suis posée on parlait de lui tout à
l'heure c'est le premier nom qui m'est
venu à l'esprit quand j'ai préparé cette
petite envolée louis burton forcément le
skipper de bureau vallée deux
originaires de rambouillet qui a presque
à tirer toute la lumière sur lui elle et
ces dernières semaines et pour cause une
troisième participation au vendée globe
l'everest des mers la compétition reine
de la voilà un départ difficile puis un
retour canon et mais les derniers
événements évoqués tout à leur montre
que rien est escompté dans cette course
autour du monde pendant trois mois il a
parcouru un peu plus de 50% du chemin
qui est encore loin vers les sables
d'olonne nous verrons à la fin de
l'événement c'est à dire des débuts 2020
s'ils arrivent à accomplir son objectif
du top 6 attendons donc encore un peu
2020 aussi vu l'éclosion de talents au
tennis notamment avec le jeune antoine
ghibaudo celui qui s'entraîne au haut
comité des yvelines de feucherolles a
participé cette année pour la première
fois à roland garros juniors sur la
terre battue parisienne libinois de 15
ans a atteint le deuxième tour après
avoir éliminé l'indien java et s'est
incliné ensuite face aux brésiliens
hayes tête de série numéro 14 deux
joueurs il faut le préciser plus âgées
que lui qui 18 ans et en 2019 fin 2019
donc c'était presque 2020 antoine
thibodeau avait atteint les demi finales
du tournoi des petits as est une
référence mondiale pour la catégorie des
moins de 14 ans je les ai vu s'entraîner
il était vraiment très très fort il est
13 enfants se anthony l'avait rencontrée
il ya très peu michael alors l'autre
jeune dont on a parlé dans cette
émission avec une photo notamment
montrant son envergure impressionnante
c'est victor wemba nyama basketteurs
évoluant dans le rôle de pivot à
nanterre sa taille à 16 ans seulement
deux mètres 19 cette saison il est
intégré de plus en plus à l'effectif
professionnel en championnat et on ne
recoupe mais il continue d'évoluer
d'évoluer aussi dans le même temps avec
l'équipe centrale fédérale qui du centre
fédéral pendant le central fédéral c'est
autre chose mais voilà l'équipe du
centre fédéral qui évolue en nationale 1
pour qu'il continue à grandir ce que
c'est important victor wemba diama
sportivement il doit continuer à grandir
en gardant la tête sur les épaules car
il y a de quoi avoir les chevilles qui
enflent plus grands espoirs du basket
tricolore on lui prédit une possible
première place à la draft 2023 en nba
mais je les ai déjà dit dans une
précédente émission laissons ces jeunes
travailler tranquillement alors avec qui
distinguait si ce n'est un sportif en
particulier une performance collective
peut-être ça va faire plaisir à pierre
qui est avec de celle du rugby club de
versailles la saison dernière les
championnats où ont été arrêtés
les gens qui n'est pas d'accord
forcément des gens le site a envoyé à
grégory pierre
vimont cash c'est ça
la saison dernière les championnats ont
été arrêtés on le rappelle mais les
joueurs de la cité royale ont clôturé l
exercice 2019 2020 une belle 4e place de
leur poule en fédérale 3 alors qu'ils
étaient est promu et l'équipe faisait
son retour dans cette division et à
batailler avec les meilleures écuries du
championnat pas de phases qualificatives
cependant en raison de l'arrêt du sport
mais elle a été proposée au rugby-club
de versailles de monter en fédérale 2 a
été finalement repoussée par les
dirigeants pour continuer de travailler
sereinement et depuis le début de la
saison les versaillais collectionne cinq
victoires et une défaite en six matches
de championnat ils sont actuels leaders
de leur poule en fédérale 3 reste à
savoir quand ils pourront reprendre nous
pouvons citer aussi l'exemple de la is
more pas en football montée historique
en régionale 3 après avoir été sacré
champion en avance de division de
district devant hardricourt il était
aussi les morts passé un demi finaliste
de la coupe des yvelines qui n'est pas
allée à son terme cette saison les mort
d'asia n'ont pas souffert jusqu'à
l'arrêt du championnat de leur statut de
promu en étant en deuxième à seulement
un point du leader l équipe réserve du
football-club de versailles qui est
leader de ce championnat de régionale 3
les yvelines décidément qui sont au top
mais je souhaitais aussi souligné lé
résultat d'un autre club alors ce n'est
pas un sport collectif mais qu'importe
le cercle des nageurs de l'ouest qui est
basée à saint germain en laye qui a
brillé lors des derniers championnats de
france avec une pluie de peau de podium
citons d'abord justin delmas 15 ans
seulement qui a décroché la médaille
d'or sur le 100 m brasse seniors aux
championnats de france grand bassin
c'était à saint raphaël est la nageuse
s'est offert en plus la meilleure
performance française des catégorie 15
16 17 ans avec ce temps une minute 8
secondes et 83 centièmes la veille elle
décroché le titre de vice championne de
france élite sur le 50 m brasse et que
dire d'alex portal 18 ans engagé lui aux
championnats de france handisport petit
bassin à angers l'athlète malvoyants qui
est déjà vice champion du monde du 200 m
il ya battu tenez vous bien quatre
records du monde 400 m nage libre 100 m
nage libre 100 m dos 200 m 4 nages à
cela il faut ajouter deux records
d'europe un record de france en 100 m
brasse alexa a déjà paris 2024 dans un
coin de sa tête il sera de la partie aux
jeux paralympiques de tokyo en 2021
reste à savoir quand ils se tiendront
est ce que je pourrais ajouter un
dernier un dernier attention très dans
le temps additionnel on l'a appris cette
semaine on en discutait en off tout à
l'heure avec pierre antoine rosemère
golfeur de 27 ans qui a été élu meilleur
joueur issu du challenge du tour cette
saison le challenger c'est l'antichambre
européenne une première saison dans
l'élite réussi pour lui qui s'entraîne
au golf de la boulie à versailles
cette année ces résultats 2e à l'open de
maurice en décembre 2019 alors ça
c'était à la fin de l'année dernière 3e
alenda soul l'andalucia masters en
espagne et vainqueur de son premier
tournoi lors du golfe dubaï championship
début décembre
bref vous l'avez compris que du beau
monde dans cette année 2020 qui est le
sportif de l'année selon vous c'est la
question que vous pose genre qui est le
sportif de l'année selon vous
alors je vais je vienne déjà beaucoup
oui oui non mais je viens d'écouter avec
le crâne atteint une grande attention
quand même grégory alors moi j'ai un
petit peu de matches sur les sur les
jeunes les parce que ce sont des espoirs
donc ce soit des espoirs c'est bien ils
performent victoire un bagnard a
entraîné d'autres pas encore ben ouais
mais c'est bon ils performent d'un
chez les jeunes j'aime voir habitants au
maniema quand même mais on est d'accord
mais moi j'ai un petit peu de mal parce
que ça
je peux je peux faire des sportifs
accomplis je peux faire et sportif
accompli c'est un choix c'était le choix
je l'expliquais pourquoi et par
solidarité vis-à-vis de mon sport et
vis-à-vis de certaines personnes je veux
dire le rugby de versailles est plutôt
la performance collective voilà je
préfère une performance collective le
virement est également bien parti pour
jean amateurs chevallier western union
qui est partie à dix jours
pierre merci à vous et joker en
forcément pour le rugby club de
versailles en petit joker pour nous à
joker joker vous pouvez pas dire by
claude de versailles jeudi à dire ok pas
d'attaquant il m'a dit
je prends comme le souffle
jean pierre dont le président
est un issu d'une famille grande famille
de golfeurs franciliens et y lit
notamment racing club de france de la
boulie qui est directement nommé par un
copain et il est donc la révélation du
tour européen cette saison il a il a
géré ça c'est ou antoine rosseler et
notamment avec un seul tour en toute fin
de saison au dubai championship il
paraît même qu il allait plus loin mais
c'est un autre français victor victor
perez qui a qui a bien performé à ce
moment là donc là mon coeur et huit mois
deux golfeurs battra pour antoine il a
une grosse marge de progression
il a une marge de progression c'est là
de toute façon ça fait ça fait déjà
quelques temps qu'il est sur le circuit
amateur comme l'était son frère
et ses parents d'ailleurs aussi qu'ils
sont maîtres de tout premier joueur des
joueurs de tout premier ordre et il a
maturé ça fait longtemps qu'ils mathieu
il a été se frotter au
golf universitaire américain et il a
effectivement maintenant dans son
entourage et dans son dans son
environnement technique toutes les
chances de bien performer donc oui une
encore encore une petite marge de
progression et là il arrive à maturité
notamment au niveau mental et au niveau
de chômage de son âge son expérience
vient de jarrier
joker sont alors bien sûr
pour moi sur la voile alors moi je vais
je vais dire personne tout simplement
parce que pour moi le sportif le sportif
il mois de l'année ça va être la
qu'ovide
et je vais jouer sa clause de jarrier ce
sont des traîtres je peux pas dire ça
mais mes gars m'ont la réalité nous
rattrape de toute façon et aujourd'hui
tout le monde n'a pas pu soit finir ces
championnats soit faire ces compétitions
et donc est donc tout le monde n'a pas
pu jouer à armes égales et donc je ne
veux pas juger les uns par rapport à
d'autres parce que certains n'ont pas pu
donc juste pas pu concourir et je vais
parler de nos de nos sportifs pistard
qui qui n'ont pas eu de contact lors du
championnat du monde qui ne pas fait une
seule coupe du monde depuis depuis la
rentrée c'est dur et il n'y a pas eu les
jeux olympiques il ya plein de choses
qu'on n'a pas pu voir a pu avoir et donc
bas
c'est difficile de mettre quelqu un en
avant alors que tout le monde n'a pas pu
pas pu exercer son transport c'est votre
votre regard il ya dujarrier alors nous
allons passer maintenant notre dernière
thématique début décembre avait lieu la
présentation du tas car 2021 et indivis
noah participera une nouvelle fois ce
rallye raid jean pierre garçon
originaire de montesson sera le copilote
de christian lavieille chez md rallye
sport après plusieurs années chez toyota
ce sera sa 22e participation la première
remontant maintenant l'édition 1997
l'année dernière les minois de 57 ans
avait terminé l'épreuve au 28e rang il
espère faire aussi bien lors de cette
43e édition qui sera organisée du 3 au
15 janvier dans les dunes d'arabie
saoudite on les écoute
pas
en plus on a changé l'équipe donc un peu
plus de motivation avec une belle
voiture
donc une belle voiture une bonne voiture
donc voila quoi c'est très bien la
question sur ce thème jean-pierre est-il
jean pierre garcin et s'il un aventurier
des temps modernes oui ou non voter
rapidement c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission partager bon je vois que vous
ça réagit pas trop le genre pourquoi
non mais je sais juste pas on va voir
l'interview
gg par cette dilatation interview
grande grande 22e participation oui oui
mais enfin j'ai juste l'impression qu'un
qui est bon et hop on repart faire un
petit tour puis c'est rigolo c'est bien
mais il n'y a pas dans son discours
vraiment un objectif sportif à 10 ans
ben on reprend on reprend le débat avec
pour objectif il a parlé d'objectif donc
ça ça me gêne un petit peu dans le paris
dakar dans une course comme le
paris-dakar que je porte un film n'est
plus chez toyota c'est chez elle des
rallyes dont qui connaît pas forcément
peut-être le potentiel de sa fenêtre
avec l'état d'esprit l'état d'esprit
fait quand même que comprend le début le
départ d'une course tels que le paris
dakar est la moindre des choses c'est
dire mon objectif et deux là aucun
moment on repart du style ouais c'est
reparti on retrouve les coupelles et
machet on va faire la java c'est presque
ça de ce discours c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti c'est pour ça que je me jette
un petit peu mitigé les gorilles mais on
parlait la nar fois des skippers au
vendée globe on parlait aussi des
derniers aventuriers on va dire des
temps modernes je pense qu'on peut
mettre alors je sais pas si on peut les
mettre sur le même plan mais en tout cas
c'est de la même veine pour pour le
paris le paris dakar avec des coureurs
on le sait qu'ils ont passé plusieurs
jours dans le désert ils vont je crois
cette année parcourir plus de 7000 km en
arabie saoudite et on a vu dans les
éditions précédentes du daaka c'était
une compétition très difficile et ça
peut être aussi dramatique comme comme
compétition donc moi je les mettrais
quand même dans cette catégorie là des
aventuriers des temps modernes après
c'est quand même plus court que le
vendée globe par exemple 1 du 3 au 15
janvier 1 cette année en arabie saoudite
pierre chevalier
là où j'étais partagé c'est que oui
c'est le dakar est une aventure
formidable avec du avec du suspect
depuis danger et de la technique mais ce
qui me fait dire qu'ils sont peut-être
de moins bons grands aventuriers que par
exemple et les voileux dont on a parlé
des marins dont on a parlé pour le
vendée globe c'est que c'est sous
assistance c'est avec assistant il ya
une caravane d'étuis quand on compare
mais quand on compare les marins qui se
console avec leur bateau en bon plein
milieu de la mer qui sont avec leurs
assistants familiaux visés c'est là où
là où je veux et si tu prends une cure
même si je salue les prestations des
pilotes du paris dakar oui ian il ya
peut-être un petit peu moins de dangers
qu avant peut-être sur le dakar
badiou mali on n'a plus 20 ans des pays
dans un pays un peu plus chaud non je
plaisante un petit peu mais pour moi
enfin voilà on est on est maintenant sur
des spéciales qui font 300 400 km on est
on est plus chasser ses plus belles
d'esprit on reste dans un seul pays j'ai
puis on parle plus de paris voilà c'est
je pense que le rallye dakar a perdu son
de son âme de son âme quand quand ils
ont changé de continent et quand ils ont
été obligés obligé par à cause d'eux
il ya dujarrier donc c'est une
compétition qui existe depuis
1978 au début c'était une compétition du
coup entre l'europe et l'afrique de
données de 2009 à 2019 c'était en
amérique du sud est depuis 2020 du coup
c'est en arabie saoudite pour l'instant
voilà c'est le continent asie le
continent avis voilà et je trouve que
ouais ça n'a plus la même ça n'a plus la
même saveur et nous français on ne le
regarde plus de la même manière on a pu
7,7 même cette même ferveur que vous
pouvez avoir quand quand le paris-dakar
partez partez du château de versailles
l'europe est le 1er janvier ou le 31
août 31 décembre voilà c'était c'était
le réveillant qu'on faisait qu'on
faisait à ce moment là moi j'en gardais
des super image et des supers souvenirs
quoi c'est bien dommage et tout ça à
cause de situation géopolitique et aider
des systèmes de guerre qui peuvent qui
peuvent avoir lieu dans le nord des pays
et c'est bien et c'est bien malheureux
le sport ne triomphe pas malheureusement
le sport le trio pas toujours
voilà mais aimer donc donc voilà c'est
vrai que maintenant on le regarde un
petit bobo de dallas est beaucoup plus
lointain on n'a plus la même les mêmes
retransmission mais même s'il a le 10 km
h lors du talk avec moins important que
le canton et en amérique du sud voilà
ccc moi c'est moins agréable à suivre
il a fini du coup 28e genre de la
dernière édition
forcément il faut qu'il fasse mieux que
ou qui termine tout simplement le dakar
c'est pas forcément une compétition
qu'on termine facilement
oui je pense que pour beaucoup déjà
c'est terminé qui est important
après bon on sait que c'est inégal aussi
puisqu'il ya là qu'il en soit les
écuries avec des assistances techniques
d'autres qui sont qui sont l'assistance
c'est eux et voilà donc les chances sont
pas les mêmes mais pour la plupart pour
des gens comme co commun c'est la
plupart c'est de finir déjà et c'est
déjà une belle aventure que de finir le
pari d'accord pour l'instant il ne l'a
pas encore gagné en 22 éditions pour
l'instant mais il voit pas cette année
on ne sait jamais en effet je suis pas
sûr qu'il a l'état d'esprit pour aller
gagner mais bon je me trompe peut-être
jamais alors c'est déjà à la fin de
cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
c'est une citation 2 cristiano à une
trame musicale musicale pour pour genre
oui c'est pour la forme c'est ça alors
donc on va terminer par une citation de
cristiano ronaldo
votre amour me renfort votre haine me
rend invincible je vous laisse méditer
sur cette phrase très belles fêtes de
fin d'année à bientôt sur tv à 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui